is definitely right now the calm before
the storm major changes are going to
kick in
as early as monday morning all the way
into that tuesday morning where we do
track a very difference in pace and
temperatures
getting relatively colder we're also
going to be tracking the possibility to
see some flurries some snow
a lot of snow happening for the
mountains and eventually
more rain down the road your almanac
will also show you that for today we're
actually
three degrees warmer than yesterday
closer to those normal temperatures
come tomorrow we're looking to drop back
into the 40's
lows for tonight will be of 36 degrees
outside right now tracking plenty of
40's for most of your area centennial
hills 42 for you the strip
in the 50's same goes for green valley
paround 49
laughlin 52 and like i mentioned we do
have various changes kicking in for
tomorrow you can see throughout the day
for your monday lower elevations can
expect
pretty much persistent light rain
throughout the entire day now we do have
winter storm warnings and winter weather
advisories
in full effect starting around 4 a.m for
your monday
into tuesday morning future cast let's
show you how this system is really going
to start to kick in
as early as this morning and you can see
it's going to start
mainly for the mountains first before it
makes its way here the las vegas valley
so we are expecting a whole lot of rain
kicking in
for the entire day and you can see the
possibility to see
that snow really starts to roll by in
the later
hours so you can expect it mainly around
that nine o'clock
through 11 p.m hour of your monday you
can see it there pushing through for
that tuesday morning those chances still
in our forecast and eventually another
system rolling by where we do expect
more clouds to kick in back again and
you can see the spring mountains getting
more of that activity of snow rain
answers our forecast back again
on friday that is another chance of rain
there satellite radar
let's show you how much snow we can
accumulate here in the las vegas valley
we want to make sure you are safe you're
checking on those roads
and you're driving with plenty of
caution out there summerlin one to two
inches of snow for you there red rock
two to eight
possibly accumulated all the way into
that tuesday morning the mountain
springs 7 to 10
the mountains definitely getting the
heavier snow amounts there now the las
vegas valley we are not expecting
any of that snow really to kick in in
our roadways i know it's pretty those
flurries look
very nice we want to make sure you pull
aside if you're looking to take some
video or
actually just take a look at it wind
speeds light in variable conditions but
gusts seem to return to stronger gusts
mainly for kingman for the baker area
ahead of that winter storm for tonight
we do
expect those lows of 43 degrees
increasing cloud coverage
and rain entering our forecast as early
after that 2 a.m start of your monday
tomorrow definitely showing you plenty
of rain kicking in
here's a look at the next seven days
where we do show you those chances for
rain really starting to
diminish rain answers our forecast back
again on friday and we'll be right back